if your family was slaughtered by
terrifying monsters what would you do
your beloved sister has turned into a
demon and now you'll need to train to
become the world's greatest Demon Slayer
in order to save your sister and take
down your family's murderer I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the demons in
Demon Slayer this kid has no idea that
he's about to watch everyone he loves
gets slaughtered by demons tanjiro here
is your regular small town kid with a
super sensitive nose more on that later
he prepares to leave his house and head
to the nearby Town wanting to sell his
family's charcoal Supply he waves
goodbye to his family and tells them
that he'll be back tonight not realizing
that by morning everyone he loves will
have their guts and insides ripped out
he heads into town but comes across a
friend who needs his help he's gotten
into trouble for breaking this lady's
pot so tanjiro uses his special nose to
help him out isn't he nice he gives this
pot a Sniff and tells this lady here
that his friend is innocent and that her
pot was broken by a nearby stray cat
this kid's superhuman nose is capable of
smelling all sorts of scents and within
the next few months he will use this
power to hunt down demons later that
night tanjiro finishes up his job in
town and heads back to his family in the
forest and then he comes across this man
he tells Tundra that it's too dangerous
to be walking around the mountain at
night and he warns him that terrifying
creatures are out on the prowl wanting
to keep him out of trouble he forces
tanjiro to spend the night with him
telling this kid that he can leave in
the morning when it's safe as he heads
inside this Man reveals to him the
terrifying reality of this world by
Sundown every night the world enters a
state of horror and brutality the Demons
of this World come out at Sunset to feed
on the living and have been doing this
for hundreds of years he tells Tundra
that to combat this threat Humanity ages
ago created demon Hunters specialized
Warriors that have existed for Centuries
with one job in mind to wipe out all of
the world's demons tanjiro thinks he's
joking but the man warns him to be on
high alert from now on the next day
Tundra hurries back to his family home
but comes across the terrifying scent he
smells blood following the strong
metallic scent he follows the scent of
blood as it leads him right to his
family a pile of corpses everyone here
has been murdered shocked he sees his
sister still alive and rushes over to
get her some help but that's when he
realizes that something is wrong she
freaks out and begins to get violent
pushing both of them off this Cliff
tanjaro then realizes that his sister
has turned into the stuff of Legends a
Bonafide demon she pounces on to him and
tries to tear him apart not wanting to
hurt her he still thinks his sister's
soul is in there somewhere inside of
this demon and he begs her to come back
to him but that's when Tundra notices
his demon sister begin to let out some
tears so it looks like she's still in
there wow I know this has been long time
coming and boy am I excited to tell you
about this one this world is filled with
terrifying demons that are basically
like vampires sort of and they all have
their own unique Supernatural powers and
are hard as hell to kill but what I'm
wondering about right now is how in the
world Tundra went to living his brief
life in a scary ass forest with his
family and none of these guys ever came
across one of these monsters that
supposedly comes out every night and
goes spooky throughout the forest like
honestly it's a miracle that his
family's death didn't happen sooner but
let's put on our Sherlock and figure out
what's going on from the crime scene and
how the doors were blown back it's
likely the demon entered the House
suddenly the blood on this door looks to
be result from a medium velocity
splatter pattern usually caused by
things such as baseball bats hammers
axes all the fun tools for murder and if
I had to guesstimate has an impact speed
between 5 to 25 feet per second
obviously these demons would likely have
been able to attack it even much faster
speeds than that but however due to the
placement of the door here and the
thicker blood dropped on the door itself
and the demons likely used their teeth
and Claws explaining why this pattern
looks like it came from someone that was
attacked with a knife or something very
sharp at very close range and everyone's
situated in this one corner here check
it out and it likely means that they
were within that spot before the Damon
entered the house and basically died
where they stood because the blood
pattern on this door over here fun fact
folks is known as a cast off pattern and
this happens when an object like an ax
covered in blood for example blings back
in an attempt to impact the victim a
second time and this flinging motion
causes whatever blood is on the weapon
to fall in the opposite direction of the
attacker Isn't that cool the tale of
this Blood pattern usually points to the
direction of where the impact came from
that the demon entered the house killing
his first victim right here before
running to the far side of the room and
causing a mess over here the panic in
this room caused the door here to blow
and our sister and our brother tried to
run but were taken down before they
could reach the doorway then based on
the transfer blood stains to either
tried to crawl out of the house while
bleeding out or they were dragged out by
the demon long story short our entire
family all died a very brutal Death and
All Happened practically within the span
of 10 seconds that is horrible and the
fact that our sister survived all of
this means that I wouldn't really count
on her personality ever coming back
anytime soon because anybody who
witnessed their own family's personal
execution and Slaughter would likely be
so screwed up for the rest of their life
out of nowhere this Warrior flies in and
nearly kills nezuko that's his sister's
name by the way and tanjaro acts fast
the man introduces himself as guiyu this
man is a legendary Demon Hunter he takes
a swipe at nezuko and tells tanjiro that
she must die and he begs giu to spare
her her life telling him that she's
still human deep down in there somewhere
he saw the tears he's not lying and he
tells him that someone else is behind
his family's murder and he whines so
much that he pisses this guy off and he
tells tanjaro to stop whining and get
over it and deal with the situation like
a man so what does he do tanjaro steps
up to the plate and throws a snowball at
him and he charges in headfirst very
stupid can you easily knocks him down
but he notices that Tantra doesn't have
his weapon suddenly he comes flying
through the air and it almost kills him
this shocks him and he realizes that
Tundra now just displayed some very
impressive Battle Tactics but then Kyo
gets knocked down by nezuko and he
watches her go to protect her brother
clearly still showing some human traits
he thinks these two might have something
special moments later Tundra wakes up to
find that his sister is alright and is
not a crazy demon face kiyo tells them
both to head to this mountain nearby and
to find a mysterious old man and he will
be able to take care of them and solve
all of their problems the two then head
off to find this old man under the
Cloudy mountain sky on the way there
they come across this Shrine but that's
when Tundra spots first proper demon
Live In the Flesh it viciously tells
them that this is his territory but he
notices nezuko instantly he attacks
Tundra but very quickly nezuko
decapitates him but he's not dead his
headless body still tries to attack them
and tanjaro nezuka both fight parts of
this demon head-on he trapped the
Demon's head into a tree the tundra then
notices by his smell that this demon is
not the one who killed his family excuse
the interruption but I wanted to break
in and give everyone a heads up about a
great New Deal from a Partners over a
factor now we all know that when it
comes to anime the best fit characters
usually win the fight and the meals for
Factor are some of the best tasting I've
had fact it makes media nutrition goals
easier than ever by delivering fresh
never Frozen dietitian approved meals
right to your doorstep the team of
gourmet chefs create each meal using
only ingredients with Integrity to help
you feel your best all day long you need
nutritious convenient meals to energize
you for warmer active days and to keep
you on track for reaching your goals
whether you're the protagonist in an
anime or a regular person Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you fuel up fast with ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door you'll eat well and Tackle
everything on your to-do list whether
you're about to do battles with another
character or star with school mystery
and I personally hate having to think
about what I'm going to eat and how long
it'll take to get to me so the fact that
factory is cheaper to take out and meals
are ready faster than restaurant
delivery in just two minutes is perfect
for me and it doesn't hurt that meals
like sun-dried tomato chicken for
example are delicious either head to
factory75.com or click the link below
and use code hdba 50 to get 50 off your
first fact of the box now back to the
video okay we've just officially
encountered our first proper demon here
but the thing that doesn't make sense is
how everything went down right before
[__] just hit the fan just now if I was
Tundra I would have talked way more with
you when we first met him and would have
taken the news that there were demons in
my backyard so lightly we were warned by
that man earlier you know the old guy
that Tundra slept in his house with we
were told that demons were active in
this area at night and our family paid
the ultimate price for it in the same
Forest the next day this means that even
going to meet this mysterious old man
think you told us about this would have
meant to us having to walk through this
Forest even longer which we already knew
wasn't 100 safe to begin with Kyu being
a Demon Hunter means that we could have
picked his his brain for a while and
gathered more info about what demons
were really out there in this forest and
how we could have defeated that by
asking him more questions about our
enemy we could have also figured out
that these creatures were basically like
vampires unable to stand directly in the
Sun have superhuman abilities and so on
now the time frame that these events are
currently set in are in the taisho era
in Japan from 1912 to 1926. so it's
possible that Japanese citizens would
have had some pre-existing knowledge of
vampire tales and folklore that would
have come from the West at that time
especially since Japan opened up to
trading with the West over 60 years ago
prior to these events fun fact it opened
up in 1853 and this means that Western
influence would have definitely already
been a thing it's also noted that the
demon we just encountered said that this
was his territory and how does the demon
even pull that off pull up a sign but
anyways this basically means that this
was his feeding area and we just stepped
into it but the fact also is that you
could have also told us about this and
would have no doubt have changed how we
would have also done things tanjaro here
should have taken a page out of
natsuno's book from Shiki and should
have actually tried to do at least some
research on the enemies he was up
against before he went out into Force
because all of this was just pathetic
but then they get approached by a
stranger wearing a mask it's the old man
he tells Tandra that the only way to
kill a demon is by destroying their head
and tells this kid that he won't cut it
but tanjiro has no idea what he's
talking about the Sun finally Rises as
everyone watches this demon get burnt
alive and Tundra sees his sister Retreat
into the shade the masked man introduces
himself as sakonji AKA old man he knows
that the Demon Hunter from earlier Q
sent tanjiro to him he tells this kid
that he thinks his fighting skills are
pathetically weak and that he's not
ruthless enough for the job of becoming
a Demon Hunter he tells these two that
they will stay with him at his house
from now on while he tests tanjiro's
abilities over the next many months and
doing this he will get his anime demon
hunting Journey started they head to the
top of the mountains as the old man
gives him his first assignment in order
to be trained by him tindro needs to
meet him at his house down below Before
Sunrise or else he'll fail the test and
just like Batman he suddenly disappears
and Tundra begins his test but he fails
instantly in all sorts of ways realizing
that the thin mounted air is making
everything more difficult he gets up and
tries to to focus on the old man's scent
eventually reaching the bottom of the
hill and passing the test and the old
man accepts him as his student in order
to become a full-time Demon Hunter
tanjiro must train in order to pass the
final test called the final selection a
terrifying trial in the forest where all
the demon hunters will go to test their
skills up against horrifying monsters
but to do that tanjaro would need to
learn the ways of the warrior first okay
this is insane what time Taro is up
against is actually more insane than he
even realizes even though demon Hunters
have been around for nearly a thousand
years the government of Japan doesn't
recognize their existence and the crazy
part is is that all of these guys all
start out as regular humans who
basically train like satama do a little
bit of breathing and turn into a
Japanese blade gaming power similar to
him enhanced speed strength reflexes and
some really sick computer graphics and
animation combining all of that they get
something known as total concentration
breathing techniques what this is is
when someone inhales the maximum amount
of oxygen within a specific breath
pattern basically to enhance all of
their senses to their maximum level
similar to real world examples where
extra oxygen supplied to the brain of
muscle can enhance cognitive or physical
performance during training so basically
learning how to breathe better to become
a better better badass Tundra begins his
training to become the world's greatest
Demon Hunter and learns all sorts of
skills sword total concentration
breathing and all 10 breath water forms
while nezuko slips into a deep coma it's
strange but the doctors can't explain it
he continues his training as one year
passes old man sakonji tells him that
his training with him is now complete
but there's one more thing he must do
first he takes tanjiro to this giant
rock and gives him his final task if he
can split this rock in two with his
Katana he'll be allowed to join the
final selection Tundra then spends many
months trying to breathe it but he can't
do it and begins to lose all hope but
that's when this kid in a fox mask shows
up tanjiro thinks this guy's another
student of old man the kid begins to MOG
him and tells him that he's still a
little boy he challenges tanjiro to show
him what he's got the two do get out but
Fox mask kid shows him who's boss it
gets even weirder because this girl
shows up out of nowhere and tells Tundra
that the kids are rooting for him as
well Tundra is even more confused than I
am right now but he begins training with
these kids and they help him develop his
skill many more months pass and fox mask
kid challenges tanjaro to another fight
but this time he's ready he attacks the
mass kid cutting off his mask and these
two kids smile and they tell Tundra to
win no matter what before they both
suddenly disappear and Tundra realizes
that he just cut through the Rock and
has passed the test finally Old Man
shows up again and is shocked he tells
Tundra that he secretly wished he would
fail this test because he doesn't want
to watch another kid die during the
final selection he pets him like Hachiko
and tells him to give the final test
everything he's got and hands him a fox
mask the next day Tundra leaves his
sister with old man and heads off to the
final selection heading into this
mystical Forest far away in the mountain
here he meets the other trainees and
these two creepy looking girls they tell
everyone here that this mountain is home
to thousands of captured demons that
can't escape this Forest thanks to these
magical trees that surround the mountain
if everyone here can survive the entire
night alive they will pass the final
selection and become a Demon Hunter okay
shit's about to get dirty real fast
because we need to realize the dangers
of what we're about to face because
there's no help coming for any of us if
we mess up and the death rate for
putting children up against thousands of
demons is probably what you'd expect
most of them die however the reality of
this death game is that it has a ton of
flaws and one big one it's stated in the
rules that candidates don't need to
actually fight any demons to pass the
test they just need to be alive by the
end of things that's a big loophole
don't you think don't you think that
would create some sort of a quality
problem from this big lack of oversight
in the rules we can assume that the best
candidates in the past the top they're
the ones that killed most of the Demons
on this mountain while the rest of them
just simply hid till the exam was over
which means that over time the demon
Slayers that are out and about right now
a good chunk of them are not that good
and probably haven't even killed a demon
yet that's kind of scary and this huge
flaw highlights another problem it has
to do with a variety of skills that a
Demon Slayer learns as a part of their
training and it's one that is not tested
here because becoming a Demon Slayer is
not just about sword skills it's about
being Master tacticians strategist being
a part of the Demon Slayer core is
basically like being a part of a special
military unit they learn and get good at
many skills but the problem is that this
tournament rules is that not everyone
here is good at everything some might be
terrible Swordsmen who will hide during
the tournament and just survive only to
die a week later when they come across
an actual demon and many great Swordsmen
here in the past have been killed during
this tournament trying to protect weaker
candidates this means I think we can
take advantage of this huge loophole in
this tournament the rules never said
that we could not team up or betray
other candidates which means we got a
lot of options to work with the more
logical move would be to band together
and utilize everyone's different
strength to survive as a full-on group
which sounds like a really good idea but
for the good of the Demon Slayer core we
probably should not let the weaker ones
survive we could backstab the [__] out
of many candidates by befriending them
at first identifying their weaknesses
and strengths and then take advantage of
that whenever we need to survive
ourselves I got a sister I have to try
to undemify now while this backstabbing
strategy would not be the most efficient
one as it would release of any purpose
since no one needs to die in order to
win the tournament then I guess we could
just help everybody and hopefully we all
survive together as a team because then
that would increase everyone's odds of
surviving and passing the final Demon
Slayer test all as friends the
competition finally starts but tanjaro
is horrified he decides to Head East
where the sun will rise the earliest and
hopes to avoid all of the demon drama
but it's too late suddenly he runs into
a nasty blood-soaked scent and figures
out that a demon is nearby he tries to
calm himself down
and uses one of the skills that the old
man taught him total concentration
breathing he floods his body with
Supernatural levels of oxygen and blood
and uses a fourth form strike to knock
the creatures down but then he hears
footsteps getting closer and closer and
he starts to realize that what's coming
is not just another demon it's something
far worse he spots a towering demon
passed by him and sees what it's chasing
this one dude and this girl as she gets
picked up and eaten alive this makes the
demon grow even bigger and shoots its
arms at this trainee capturing him
Tundra quickly reacts and saves him
using the breath of the water second
form the demon then spots tanjiro's Fox
mask and lets out a Sinister chuckle it
recognizes the mask it tells tanjaro
that it knows his master old man 50
years ago old man captured this demon
and trapped him on this magical Mountain
it then reveals to tanjaro something
horrifying wanting revenge against old
man this demon made it his life's
mission to brutally Feast on every
single one of old man's students that he
sent to the final selection and over the
last 50 years none of them made it out
alive including the last kid who wore
the very mask on tantaro's face Fox mask
guy and the little girl time to roll's
eyes widened and he furiously tries to
attack this demon but he's too weak he
focuses on his training and thinks fast
quickly attacking from the air and again
he uses his sick breath of water moves
to rain down hell on this demon swiftly
killing it well done and he sees The
Souls of all the children that this
demon murdered all of the old man's
ex-students finally being set free he
goes on to kill more demons and survives
the night the next morning the remaining
trainees remain standing and everyone
here passes the final selection test
after they meet with this Demon Slayer
lady who assigns each one of them a
personal bird assistant which will also
provide them with new demon hunting
bounties now a full-on Demon Slayer
Tundra heads back to meet with old man
and nezuko but is shocked to see that
she's now awake old man thinks that
nezuko was sleeping all this time to
regain energy and this is how she
avoided eating human flesh later he
tells tanjaro all about the different
types of demons that he will come across
on his adventures some can even cast
spells using their blood known as Blood
Demon Arts how original eventually he
receives all of his official demon
hunting gear including this sick plate
oh it's beautiful and then his Crow
updates him that his first devil hunting
Mission has arrived ready to go old man
gives Tundra a special sunlight proof
box keep nezuko in during the day and he
reveals something huge he tells him that
there may be one demon in the world that
could possibly cure his sister the very
first demon ever created this demon can
use his blood to change humans into
demons and tells him to go find a man
named muzan kibutsuji this man will ruin
tanjiro's life before he even knows it
the two then hug it out and this kid
declares that he will save his sister an
avenge whoever killed his family how
Noble and old man wishes him good luck
and they part ways later tanjiro then
heads off on his first devil hunting
Mission he reaches this town the
citizens tell him what's going on girls
have started to go missing every night
and it's only getting worse tanjiro
promises he'll solve the case and talks
to one of the victim's brother he says
that his sister disappeared a few days
ago and needs help finding her so what
does he do he begins sniffing around
literally for the missing girls and that
he he picks up the scent of a demon but
something is off he tracks the scent
late into the night and finally picks up
the demons he can tell they're nearby
and runs to find them running into this
alley he doesn't see anything using his
powers he takes out his sword and stabs
it into the ground saving this guy's
sister just in time Tundra asks the
demon where's the rest of the girls that
it abducted but it starts making a
strange sound knowing he's in for a
fight he radies his sword but then finds
out that there's not one demon but three
okay here we go this demon looks like it
uses Blood Demon Arts which is basically
like magic that some demons who are
strong enough can do and with each demon
being able to do different things and
already we have one advantage this demon
has revealed some of its powers to us
already we don't have to wonder and
worry about what this demon is capable
of a demon that hasn't revealed their
powers until the last moment is one that
is far more dangerous because we don't
know what to expect this one though has
already revealed some of its powers this
demon has the power to divide itself
into three which makes me wonder is it
possible that the division of the bodies
also means a division in power which is
great news for us which means we can
divide and conquer but we are
outnumbered so we do have to be careful
if I was Tundra I wouldn't leap in right
away I would observe as much as I can
and try to get this demon to reveal its
powers because just by observing their
actions and how they talk if you pay
attention you can pick up on the
original full Demon's actual personality
one of the Demons appears to be more
calm and analytical one is more violent
and impulsive driven and one has no
visible emotions but relies more
Instinct much like a rabid hunting dog
this means if I was time to row I would
look to as I said divide and conquer and
take out the brains out of the three
this will allow us to focus our efforts
on the impulsive driven one next take
him out and then we can take out the
dumb hunting dog that's what I would do
what would you do Tundra realizes that
since all the demons have the same scent
it must be dividing itself into three
people he quickly uses his waterfall
base and power to attack them but he
isn't fast enough out of nowhere the
demons burst out of this wall nearby and
almost kill Tantra but his sister neziko
steps out to save him the three evil
demons get really confused why a demon
and a Demon Hunter are working together
but nezuko ready her brother to take
down all three of these demons Tundra
tells her to watch these two kids as he
jumps deep into the demon puddle heading
down into another dimension as he chases
after the main demon about to get
attacked he summons a sixth form massive
wave whirlpool and barely manages to
kill all of these demons but meanwhile
nezuko protects these innocent children
from the final demon but Tundra comes
back from the demon Dimension and works
with his sister to take this final demon
down he interrogates it and asks what he
knows about his master the very first
demon ever created muzan but the demon
sits in shock at the sound of that name
and says that he can't snitch on his
master or else he'll Safra fate worse
than death desperate it tries to attack
Tundra but gets slain frustrated at
getting nowhere with finding a cure for
Nesco so far Tundra can do nothing but
be happy with the fact that his first
hunting mission is complete he leaves
the town with his sister and this Crow
gives him his next mission and it's one
mission that will change everything okay
Tandra listen to me brother you did good
you took out the demons but you better
not be letting it go to your head
because from what I've seen from you so
far I'm offering is that while you're
out here killing demons which you really
try to do is gather more information
about muzon all the freaking time
through all the demons that you plan on
finding now while the plan itself does
sound good it's simple it's smart learn
more information about your enemy and
learn how to take him down but how
you're going about this Tundra is what
doesn't make sense because think about
it my weebs each demon that he tries to
interrogate for five minutes will never
talk about muzan and since from what we
saw with the swamp demon muzon has the
ability to kill them instantly if they
snitch about him if I was Tundra I would
opt to play the long game in terms of
finding out some more information about
the demon Kingpin from every demon we
meet and you want to know how I'll do it
is by only going on demon hunting
missions from now on with the intent to
capture and not kill the next demon that
we see yes I know it's harder to capture
than kill but come on we need
information we need them alive not dead
but if you're able to capture a demon
and over time slowly starve it over the
next several days and weeks this would
likely weaken the demons resolve to hold
out any information that they might know
about Busan but we have to be careful
about our questions any question that we
could ask could possibly have this demon
end up dying by capturing the demon and
starving it it will behave just like
humans because hunger affects the brain
and causes one to become a little bit
impaired unable to make rational
decisions we have to break this Demon's
will which means that before long this
demon will beg for food and it is at
that moment that we will have the power
to truly get information he must head to
Tokyo because more reports of demons
emerging have been flowing in from there
later that night they finally reached
Tokyo but tanjiro is a hungry boy so he
owes himself some Ramen but then he
picks up a familiar demon scent the same
scent he picked up when his family was
murdered he rushes to find the demon
that killed his family and runs into the
first demon ever created muzan Tundra
tries to kill him but he now realizes
that this freak has a human family that
he's using as a cover he freezes up and
doesn't know what to do and that was his
biggest mistake Busan then subtly
slashes the back of this human guy's
neck and he quickly begins transforming
into a demon guiding this lady as the
crowd begins to freak out and panic
Tundra realizes that uh he messed up and
runs to help this poor man meanwhile
muzan quickly leaves with his family the
Demon Hunter just got played and yells
out to muzan that he will find him and
kill him soon the police then show up
and Tantra begs them to help him but
they don't believe him and are about to
beat him up when a magical Mist
surrounds everyone here oh okay tantaro
you got really lucky because you just
came across the most powerful Demon King
in existence this guy is the OG demon
and has existed for over a thousand
years his powers are basically Limitless
and he could have killed you instantly
and despite time to Rose Demon Slayer on
her title he rushed in way too quickly
he could have got himself killed I get
it if I was him I would be deep in the
fields too I would want revenge but I
would plan a little bit first because
from the looks of things muzan certainly
didn't see us coming another did we
which was in part due to the large
population of citizens surrounding us
which could have thrown off his scent of
us or US finding him right away or it
could be because he was with his fake
family and he simply wasn't as alert
with them as he usually is alone
regardless he didn't see us and this
means we could have been way more sneaky
to begin with being sneaky is the way
more logical thing to do because upon
discovering his scent Tantra should have
trout him first to get an idea of what
he's truly up against analyze his habits
and surroundings where does he go where
does he frequent who does he talk to
more often than not because him being
literal demon royalty means that he
probably would have been alone really
which means you got to keep your
distance for real you're not just gonna
be able to waltz in and kill this Demon
King right away you gotta have a plan
because if he had followed him he would
have seen muzan's attack on these drunk
fools and here Tundra could have gotten
a taste of the type of person that moves
on is Tundra you could have learned
right here that muzan's real goal is to
one day make the demon race resistant to
sunlight or at least himself this could
have given us a huge advantage of
knowing his desires and later used this
against him and yes unfortunately tantro
you will have to be okay with letting
him kill some innocent people but too
bad man it's for the greater good but
the one thing that tantro did find out
by going ahead first like an idiot was
the fact that muzan when he got
discovered quickly turned someone else
nearby into a demon to keep Tantra
distracted he could have just easily
killed tantaro right then and there this
makes me suspect that despite this Demon
King's gay reputation he does doesn't
want to have the spotlight yet he
doesn't want to attract unwanted
attention and even more likely demon
Hunters who are actually really skilled
and possibly an actual threat to him the
smoke protects Tundra while he has no
idea what's going on and this mysterious
woman walks up to him with this guy she
tells him that she's curious about him
wanting to help a demon and tanjiro
realizes that this woman is a demon but
also a Healer and a magical enchantress
she tells him that she also wants to
destroy muzon nearby muzan drops his
family off and tells him that he now has
to go to work he waves them goodbye and
takes the shortcut down this alley he
bumps into a group of drunk fools and
this guy says that he wants muzon suit
muzan gets pissed off and shows everyone
here why he's the top dog around here he
kills this guy and his friend and after
he walks up to this girl that's with
them and he tells her that he's the only
life form on Earth that's close to
Perfection he gently stabs his finger
right through her head and forces her
body to take in an excess amount of
blood making her body unable to deal
with the DraStic change she quickly
turns into something nasty dies right
here he then snaps his fingers into a
his henchmen show up he tells them that
he wants to find the kid wearing these
special earrings and to kill him
immediately meanwhile Tundra heads back
to his sister to grab her but runs into
green-haired guy from earlier he tells
her that the Healer demon has invited
them back to her house to stay he then
guides these two to the secret house and
they meet with the mysterious woman she
introduces herself as Tamayo and tells
tanduro that they're basically good
demons that heal people and buy donated
blood from poor people in order to
survive pandro then tells her that this
must be why he couldn't smell their
demon scent before Tamayo tells him that
despite what people think she too can
create demons just like the Demon Lord
moves on because she turned green hair
guy into a demon over 200 years ago and
reveals that she only turns people on
the verge of death into demons if they
want to continue living knowing that
she's his greatest shot at curing nezuka
he asks her if there's a way to turn
Demons back into humans and asks if she
can do it but he has no idea that demons
are nearby tracking their location
Tamayo tells Tundra that there might be
a way to cure his sister but she'll need
a large quantity of demon blood first to
research a cure but not just any even
blood she needs demons filled with Lord
muzon's Blood The Chosen Demons of his
personal Army the best of the best and
she suspects that nezuko's blood may
also help her discover a cure since she
hasn't fed on blood since she became a
demon and is still not batshit crazy but
suddenly a ball violently crashes into
the house and they see two demons
Standing Outside they tell tanjiro hello
we've been sent to kill you and anyone
that's with you the good guys prepare to
battle against this girl using a
handball as a weapon and she throws more
balls into the house and it rips right
through green hair guy's head tindero is
furious but he notices that their scent
is different he brings out his Demon
Hunter moves combined with his total
concentration breathing to enhance his
body stopping this ball but he realizes
that this ball is moving by itself
suddenly green hair guys had regenerates
and freaks tanjiro alfurious he quickly
teams up with tanjiro to take them down
okay this is a problem these demons are
another one of muzan's Minion bastards
but these ones have blood demon powers
that are a little bit more trippy this
handball girl can throw deadly handballs
at Wicked speeds and is basically way
more lethal anime version of the movie
Dodgeball that's scary but I'd be more
worried about her partner because this
guy not only has the ability to track
Footprints he has the ability to control
the vector of someone using invisible
arrows meaning he can send you up down
sideways through the air and splatter
you onto the ground if he wants to and
he can do this from a distance this
makes him way more of a direct threat
than demon girl but if we notice Arrow
demon presently is nowhere to be found
even though he clearly has been sent to
kill us and even just by hearing
babuzan's temper and knowing what he
does to his minions if they don't follow
his orders it's likely that this Arrow
guy isn't just chilling outside but is
actually contributing to the fight
somehow but with him not being present
and in my line of sight means that we
can take any undue risks if anything it
makes me think that he's like muzan he
doesn't like to get his hands dirty and
will probably attack from a distance so
what I would do if I was tanjiro I would
use green hair guy and Tamayo to keep
demon girl distracted while I tell
nazico to walk out to the back of this
house and check out the perimeter of
this building and eventually attack the
demon girl from behind keeping her
distracted and possibly using our own
sister as a shield of meat brutal I know
but she's a dangerous Shield of meat so
she might be fine but by doing this this
would allow us to scan the area and find
the aerodemon to take him out because
this demon girl clearly is immature as
is a short fused personality that makes
me think that despite her powers and
Killer Instinct she's the least of our
problems this demon assassin declares
that she's part of the 12 demon moves
direct minions of the first demon muzan
she grows multiple arms and doubles her
striking power throwing lethal handballs
all throughout this house Tantra begins
to struggle to keep tabs on all the
balls so green hair guy lends him his
demon eye Powers allowing Tundra to see
the direction of all the balls as they
come to him meanwhile nezuko goes to
find the other demon outside because he
must be the one controlling the balls
finding him she tries to stop him giving
Tundra an opening to cut this Demon's
hands he thinks he's done it but she
grows back all of her arms with ease and
nezuko gets thrown onto tantaro green
hair guy then steps in and instructs
Tundra to take care of that Aero demon
while Haman Tamayo take care of handball
girl nezuko charges at this demon but
she gets her foot blown off and knocked
back Tamayo tells her that because she
hasn't drank any blood her healing
powers have slowed down and she injects
her with some medicine outside tantaro
tries to fight Arrow guy but he can't
beat him he then uses the sixth form to
move around the arrow and showing the
distance between them he then uses a
sword Whirlpool to use a second for
modified lateral water wheel chopping
this guy's head off whew that was a
mouthful but the arrow demon is tougher
than he thinks and it's still alive he
uses his powers to fling Tantra all
around through the air until eventually
he dies but leaves Tundra injured as
hell he crawls back to check on the rest
of his teammates and finds green hair
guy working on fighting handball girl he
almost gets killed again as nezuko saves
him and quickly pets him since he
reminds her of her brother being unlike
the rest nezuko suddenly reveals her
true power level and begins taking on
handball girl with ease shocking Tamayo
because she hasn't had any blood
handball girl then gets really mad and
demands that they die here so she can
please her master Lord moves on but lady
Tamayo reveals to handball girl the true
nature of Lord moves on she tells her
that he uses demons to kill other demons
to keep their ranks small and this is
how he makes sure that there's never
enough demons in the world that are
strong enough to overthrow him she then
sneakily casts a spell onto this demon
and then handball Girls starts revealing
a little bit too much much information
about who Lord muzan really is but that
she realizes what she's done and Tamayo
tells her that she just casted a spell
on her that makes people tell the truth
knowing she's messed up handball girl
begs Lord muza to spare her life but the
curse he put on her attacks her making
her brutally explode with three hands
busting out of her body and it squashes
her head it's gory but brilliant after
that lady Tamayo tells Tantra that Lord
was on cells reside in all of the demons
out there but reveals that the demons
they just killed aren't part of the
demon 12 moons because they're too weak
it's strange and tanjiro realizes that
Lord muzon lied to handball girl and
arrow guy earlier and used them as His
pawns instead tomayo then takes a blood
sample to work on nezuko's cure and
heads inside and Tundra hears a strange
voice coming from handball girl's corpse
it asks him to play handball with her
and he realizes that deep down this
demon was just an innocent child and he
watches her get burnt alive at the
morning sun tanjaro collapses in sadness
because it's really really sad I'm not
even kidding Tamayo then updates them
that they'll need to move to safe houses
because they've been discovered her and
green hair guy tells that they'll
continue to work on a cure to save
nezuko and Tundra waves these two
goodbye for now as him and his sister
follow their Crow onto their next demon
hunting assignment and Tundra viles to
find and kill Lord muzat the demon
responsible for his family's murder
responsible for nesco's demon
transformation and the murder of many
innocent more victims and if you don't
want to get bitten by no horrifying
Japanese demons and like comment let us
know what you liked it of course they
like don't forget to check out the
playlist down below